good morning Hank it's Valentine's Day
yeah so I was watching the television
program Swamp People recently and one of
the characters on that show said I like
knowing how to do things and it occurred
to me that one I don't know how to do a
lot of things and to a lot of the things
I do know how to do or things I'm not
particularly proud of like knowing how
to watch Swamp People so three I thought
I would make a video today about six
things I know how to do and proud to
know how to do and love doing first I
know how to play disco golf with Willie
Hank he's so good at disco golf second I
know how to read Hank I'm trying to read
50 books in 2012 and so far I've read
two great ones first the art of fielding
by Chad Harbach this is definitely a
book for so-called grown-ups but I can't
remember the last time I enjoyed reading
a story more it's just beautiful and
also it made me feel all the things and
secondly Hank sometimes longtime
nerdfighters publish books and sometimes
those books are wonderful like the
statistical probability of love at first
sight by longtime nerdfighter Jennifer
Smith it's amazing it's beautifully
written it's super romantic but it's
also extremely thoughtful I was very
blown away by it very blown away I'm a
novelist
so anchored the books I've read so far
in 2012 those are my two favorite
another thing I know how to do watch
soccer now if you may remember that the
Swindon down Swilly poopers won the 2011
FA Cup now I gotta want to take credit
for this or anything but the actual
Swindon Town Football Club perhaps
inspired by my success he's having an
amazing season like if a good chance of
winning their league League two which is
actually the fourth League and inger
soccer is very confusing also they're in
the finals of the Johnstone's Paint
Trophy competition thing they get to
play at Wembley also hang on the subject
of this movie Cooper's one of our
players Fitz Hall nicknamed
one-size-fits Hall is an actual player
and the actual team that he plays for
not Swindon Town has apparently adopted
one of our cheers that we made up for
him he's big he's small he's also short
and tall one-size-fits-all
one-size-fits-all I don't know if that's
chanting or singing but if it's singing
I apologise
another thing I know how to do Hank not
to brag watch YouTube Hank I mention
this last week but I've become obsessed
with the youtuber CGP grey who's just
brilliant I mean he hates pennies
he loves Britain he's just like me
except smarter
so watch CGP grey which is not my
nickname for my pants there's a link in
the doobly-doo right below me v Hank I
know how to answer questions ok for
people who have finished The Fault in
Our Stars and only for people who have
finished the Fault in Our Stars I have
created a password-protected blog where
you can go and read
my answers to questions and comment and
basically you know discuss the book link
in the dooblydoo only if you finish the
book I mean the link is in the
doobly-doo regardless of whether you
finished it but you know what I mean and
finally Hank like everyone on the
Internet I know how to disrupt systems
of content delivery so I guess you know
I'm not a big fan of illegal disruptions
of content delivery systems I think that
stealing has been around for a long time
and there's nothing particularly
revolutionary or cool about it but Hank
I'm a huge fan of finding ways to
directly connect people who like stuff
to the stuff they like I think that's
one of the reasons I love the website
Kickstarter if Julia Nunes wants to make
an album she no longer has to go to like
venture capitalists or record companies
to get the money to make an album that
revolution strikes me as a very big deal
and I should mention the people at
thought-bubble you know the people who
do the amazing animations for crash
course they are kick-starting an awesome
documentary they want to make it if
enough nerdfighters help fund it then we
nerdfighteria will be the executive
producers of the movie so you could
check that out on the doobly-doo that's
what I love about Kickstarter it's about
us it's also what I'm about the
foundation to decrease worldsuck we both
raised the money together and spend the
money together and Hank there's a new
website that we're both obsessed with
called Gumroad calm that basically
directly connects people who make stuff
to people who like that stuff with no
one in between no PayPal no Amazon no
iTunes just you and the people and then
you know a little bit of a cut for
Gumroad but smaller than PayPal and
without PayPal Gumroad was created by an
amazing 19 year old you can check it out
upload your stuff sell it to people who
love you Hank projects like Gumroad and
Kickstarter make me think that someday
the internet might actually become the
artistic utopia we all dream about a
place where you can make a living by
making things you care about with and
for people you care about unfortunately
due to overeager grammarians the
internet will never be a place where it
is okay to end a sentence with a
preposition so I apologize overeager
grammarians Hank I will see you on
Friday